carrusel de las artes
maría carolina piña
[Música]
bienvenidos a este nuevo número de
carrusel de las artes hoy tengo el
agrado de presentarles nuestro programa
desde la ciudad ros a toulouse en el
suroeste de francia una ciudad que se
convierte cada año en una vitrina del
cine latinoamericano en el marco del
festival cine latino
sí
américa latina' vuelve a ser la invitada
estrella del festival cine latino de
toulouse unas 90 películas
latinoamericanas recientes se proyectan
en 2022 y 3 competencias en
largometrajes cortos y documentales cine
latino rinde homenaje al emblemático
patricio guzmán cineasta de la memoria
histórica de chile- las salas de cine de
toulouse proyectan toda su obra
documental cinelatino festeja también
los 20 años de cine en construcción una
plataforma de apoyo financiero para la
postproducción de películas
latinoamericanas y en este programa
iremos también el encuentro de las
mujeres que hacen hip hop y que utilizan
la música como una poderosa herramienta
de expresión feminista
[Música]
esto no va para más yo tengo que hablar
de todos
lo queríamos conocerte
carrusel de las artes se encuentra en
cinelatino festival que vuelve a tomar
las alas de la ciudad de toulouse luego
de una edición virtual en 2021 el
festival llega a sus 34 años de
existencia como siempre con competencias
en largometrajes cortos y documentales y
una selección de películas que ya han
pasado por cinelatino y cintas para el
público infantil
[Música]
12 películas inéditas en francia fueron
seleccionadas en la categoría
largometrajes de ficción y el festival
comenzó en 2022 con la proyección de la
francisca una juventud chilena 'ópera
prima' de rodrigo y litorial yo soy una
no logré sonntag en mi hermanito diego
cine latino 2022 se inauguró con un
retrato fresco y juvenil filmado en el
norte de chile en tocopilla francisca
sueña con dejar su pueblo árido y
monótono también sueña con ayudar a su
hermanito autista con el que tiene una
conexión especial la llegada de un nuevo
profesor para su hermano la llena de
esperanzas pero esta ventana abre un
mecanismo con consecuencias
irreversibles esta es la historia de la
francisca una juventud chilena primera
película de rodrigo litorial quiere
hacer referencia a dos cosas
fundamentalmente mi propia trayectoria
de vida en el norte de chile en los años
90 que fue un momento en el que viví en
iquique desde esa fecha tengo la idea de
llevar todo ese contexto cultural y
geográfico al cine también el carácter
tal vez y ensimismado de estos últimos
30 años de vida política
en chile que tuvieron un punto de
inflexión al 2011 con primeras revueltas
estudiantiles y a partir de ahí quise
inventar una protagonista juvenil
representativo de la generación de una
cierta generación de jóvenes en chile
[Música]
yo quería no hace un retrato de una
sociedad sí misma de una juventud
enclaustrada que no tiene apoyo
institucional que no tiene apoyo del
mundo de los adultos y que se hace cargo
también de las generaciones futuras
entonces hacemos ese retrato un poco con
la idea digamos de generar la necesidad
de generar un cambio los singulares que
en el proceso de edición digamos surgió
el proceso de revueltas sociales y
quedamos con una especie de película que
tal vez anuncia de una cierta manera una
situación que termina creándose en la
realidad yo creo que podemos llegar
hasta aquí que con esa moto
iquique arica la paz hasta ríos y este
año sin el latino de toulouse rinde
homenaje al chileno patricio guzmán una
figura tutelar del documental
latinoamericano su obra concebida desde
su exilio forzado en francia cuenta el
chile que dejó atrás el golpe militar
contra salvador allende dos suboficiales
y carabineros deberán desobedecer las
órdenes de los oficiales golpistas
cinelatino presentó las obras
fundamentales de patricio guzmán aunque
el cineasta chileno no estuvo presente
por un problema de salud se proyectaron
su trilogía de la batalla de chile y su
más reciente trío conformado por
nostalgia de la luz el botón de nácar y
la cordillera de los sueños pues son dos
trilogías muy diferentes muestran una
gran evolución en el cine de patricio
guzmán la trilogía de la batalla de
chile es realmente un cine de testimonio
no había un proyecto de película preciso
cuando el equipo de guzmán que era muy
joven empezó a filmar lo que estaba
ocurriendo en chile entre 1970 y 1973
sino que lo tomaban como un registro de
la historia en marcha se estaban dando
cuenta que era un momento importante de
la historia de chile y de la historia
internacional
dice diferencias es parte de la historia
asociada al agua el hielo para forjar
tratamiento asociado a la muerte la
matanza el abuso
en cambio la última trilogía que empezó
en el 2010 nostalgia de la luz se
estrena en 2010 y después del botón de
nácar y cordillera de los sueños es la
última faceta de su trabajo es un
trabajo bastante más poético y con
reflexiones siempre ligadas a la
historia de chile y al momento del golpe
de la dictadura lo que pierde chile con
esa dictadura en particular y la
necesidad de hacer memoria sobre la
represión que han sufrido los chilenos a
partir del golpe de estado pero lo
inserta en una reflexión mucho más
universal digamos del ser humano el
golpe fue el temblor de tierra más
fuerte que cambió nuestras vidas para
siempre esa lucha contra las dictaduras
fue uno de los motores de el propio
festival es ayudar a américa latina a
través de la ayuda al cine es obviamente
un cineasta emblemático para él del cine
pero que también es como representativo
de lo que defiende el cine latino desde
hace tanto tiempo yo me hago una
pregunta habrá pasado lo mismo en otros
planetas la actitud de los más fuertes
habrá sido igual en todas partes
cinelatino de toulouse celebra en 2022
los 20 años de cine en construcción un
dispositivo solidario que ha permitido
financiar la postproducción de
226 cintas de américa latina y esta
historia comenzó con un largometraje
argentino bolivia de israel adrián
caetano para hablarnos de todo esto
fuimos al encuentro de la fundadora de
cine latino y 'cine en construcción'
esther de sant vice
en el 99 recibimos a un joven productor
matías monsters inc que venía con una
película en su equipaje que era bolivia
y no lograba acabar la película estaba
rodada pero le faltaba toda la
postproducción de imagen de sonido
incluso algunas secuencias
entonces quería encontrarse con los
profesionales que estaban aquí al
festival pues para pedir ayuda entonces
organizamos su más bien improvisamos una
sesión muy especial presentamos la
película que estaba por sin terminar y
con esa presentación matías logró
terminar esta primera película
y en la sala estaba josé maría riba
miembro de la dirección del directorio
de el festival de san sebastián
y la película de gustó mucho y fue
seleccionada en la semana de la crítica
y luego consiguió un premio yo creo por
todos los festivales donde pasó el
correcto un montón de premios y así fue
que nació sin en construcción y por allí
pasaron pues un montón de joven cineasta
y que son unos cineastas pasas
internacionalmente reconocidos
[Música]
lo que hacemos es contestar a una
demanda
digamos que un valor fundamental
del festival y de cine en construcción
es la solidaridad y por supuesto que esa
demanda sirve
[Aplausos]
[Música]
mientras el dios
el imán
la gente entonces vamos a parís para
tomarle la temperatura al mundo del hip
hop y del rap pero en versión femenina
natalia olivares fue a la convención
anual del hip hop y pudo conocer a
cantantes que decidieron alzar su voz
estamos en el barrio 19 de parís aquí
hemos asistido a la convención l 2p
sobre el hip hop en francia y uno de los
temas que nos interesó particularmente
fue el lugar de las artistas mujeres en
esta industria vamos a buscar a las
raperas francesas
[Música]
no deberíamos hacer cosas que no
queremos sólo para poder expresarse con
nuestra música
[Música]
desde los años 80 siempre han estado
presentes permanecieron invisibles en
los 90 casi una mujer firmó con una gran
productora en la década de 2000
comenzaron a hacerse más visibles entre
2015 y 2017 en la época del movimiento
[Música]
el movimiento hasta actitud también
alcanzó la industria musical con
eslóganes como hashtag music
[Música]
juntos en la industria de la música las
mujeres están en peligro de manera
general no es una locura decir esto el
porcentaje de mujeres agredidas
moralmente o sexualmente o cuyas
carreras han sido bloqueadas es enorme
no sé
[Música]
dónde están las raperas la convención
del hip hop en francia descarta el
término de rap femenino que no ha
servido para la emancipación de las
mujeres para algunas incluso alimentó
una imagen falsa o distorsionada de las
mujeres en el hip hop así cascón
[Música]
hamsik fue axel y fama en los vídeos
siempre son las mujeres las que hacen
perreo nunca los hombres sin embargo los
hay mostrar que un hombre puede pelear
ni siquiera debería sorprender o no
deberíamos decir que rompe los códigos y
aunque aquí trajes y cuentos el
personalización las fans la
hipersexualización de las mujeres
fenómeno que juega en su contra pero en
realidad también permite a reapropiarse
de su cuerpo sobre todo cuando hemos
sido víctimas de ciertas cosas o cuando
hemos estado cargadas de prejuicios toda
nuestra vida puede convertirse en una
poderosa herramienta para la
autoafirmación tanto artística como
personalmente puede ser más fuerte pero
también hay otras formas de transmitir
el mensaje tras pasar la mañana de una
astilla de tendón y valor la forma en
que hemos entregado las normas los
valores y nuestra percepción de la
diferencia es una construcción social
por lo que significa que podemos
cuestionar la y deconstruir los juegos
de acción
no busquen más a las raperas francesas
porque aquí están sus voces y sus
estilos se oyen en la escena alternativa
un primer escaño antes de conquistar el
género musical más escuchado en francia
se use no quieren una quizá un papel
puros y chus es gracias natal el y bares
y con el tema montiel de la rapera y sai
así que vamos a terminar este programa
que tuvimos el gusto de presentarles
desde el festival cine latino de
toulouse muchísimas gracias por su
sintonía y hasta la próxima jaua
floricultura pasión y el aplauso tour
eiffel acaban de pasar un poco
más
[Música]
cómo
no
lo sé
[Música]